[Music]
bart
you hire people or you have had hired or
what yeah
hired i've sired people you sired
what about them so do you ever test your
interviewees
what do you mean test them oh all the
time wait what do you mean by testing
though
interviewers either easy yes
[ __ ] what is wrong with you what's going
on it's the end of the day one of my
favorite questions i always like to ask
is what is something that's embarrassed
that you're embarrassed about that
you've never told anyone else
really yeah i was like i've heard it in
public i wanna know some of these
answers so i can't tell you on camera
but
i've heard some heard crazy [ __ ] why
would people like
say all of that personal [ __ ] right so
what if they answer and they're like
they're like i was honest and you're
like yeah but you crazy dog i don't want
you working for me
but what if they're like i don't know
you like that sir so i'm not gonna tell
you that yet yeah
what are you looking for yeah i'm just
looking just to see like who they really
are because like every other question i
think people
have heard already so they're super
prepared and they give you the most
cookie cutter [ __ ] and i'm like
i don't even know after i've been
talking to this food for like 15 minutes
i still don't know where the [ __ ] this
goes you should have been like what's
your favorite color
and then they'll be like red or anything
that they say you'll be like really
and then are you sure and then they'll
be like
and then they'll be like no no it's
green and you'll be like no
oh yeah i guess so are you sure you're
just judging them to see how they react
you say what's your favorite color they
say like green and then
you are like hold on a second and then
you pick up the phone and then you go on
the phone for like a half hour
and then like what's up what a waste of
time
yeah he said green you said green right
yeah
that's funny um but yeah so
on reddit on the subreddit life pro tips
there was this one story and it says
today a candidate blew his interview in
the first five minutes after he entered
the building oh no
dismissive to the receptionist she
greeted him and he barely made eye
contact she tried to engage
him in conversation again no eye contact
no interest in speaking with her
what the candidate did not realize was
that the receptionist was actually the
hiring manager
she called him back to the conference
room and explained how every single
person
on our team is valuable and worthy of
respect
due to his interaction with the
receptionist the hiring manager did not
feel he was a good fit
thank you for your time but the
interview is over be nice to everyone in
the building what did he do
i got a [ __ ] job interview yeah
probably hi [ __ ] my name is jonathan
like what did he do i feel like it was
probably just awesome like he's probably
just like
yeah hey um yeah yeah 11 30. okay cool
like you know
not like because you know when you're on
interview mode you're supposed to be
like oh
hey how you doing nice to meet you like
very you know like putting your best
foot in the interview
starts the minute the minute you enter
the building yeah exactly
where's the toilet and she's like down
the hall to the left and he's like yeah
no i think i'm gonna go right here and
then it goes to the right
in her lap yeah i think i found the
toilet actually i think i was talking to
him but she's like you know what
he made eye contact with me the whole
time that's right and that's the type
and he tried to flush he kept on
touching my ear
which is good it's a good sign
good sign oh man yeah so someone else
wrote bingo
like a comment under that post they put
bingo after a candidate
leaves one of the first things those
involved in the interview will do is
speak to the receptionist and ask them
how the interviewee
treated them the person could be the
nicest person for the position but if
they treated the pers
the rep the receptionist like a
c word they are done if they treated it
if they treated the receptionist like
[ __ ] when they're on the best
behavior imagine how awful they will
treat them once they get the job
same goes for any cleaning staff they
are consulted too
and someone else said i got hired once
because i held the door for the janitor
coming in with his cart the receptionist
said
that's so nice of you i said it was just
decency but apparently she was
the hiring manager she was in the higher
manager's ear later that day
the choice was between me and someone
more knowledgeable
but never choose the knowledgeable one
arrogant [ __ ]
exactly i always uh question when
they're over
enthusiastic and like super
like hey how's it going yeah it's like
why are you being so
fake you [ __ ] i'm not fake i'm on coke
because this is how you are on coke i
thought i was doing good
no but you know what i learned a [ __ ]
life lesson one time on a job interview
because um first like my first interview
at california pizza kitchen
first of all i walked up and i was
wearing a [ __ ] like i was going just to
turn in my
job application and i had [ __ ] tim's
on
and like a puffy lrg jacket with like
fur and [ __ ] and i was like okay here's
my application
and the guy's like you want to do the
interview and i was like right now
and he's like yeah i was like i'm
wearing fur and he goes
let's do it i'm like all right cool so
it's like right there i was like all
right straight
let's do it and i'm you know i'm being
i'm being i'm
giving my interview voice all that [ __ ]
yeah and then he goes let me ask you
this what's your what's your least
favorite food
and i was like um i don't know i'm not
too picky he's like what what
what do you avoid and i'm like i guess
i'm not a huge fan of like bell peppers
he's like okay tell me about your bell
pepper pizza and i went
okay um it's not my anywhere and i was
like oh
ask me again ask me again that's me he's
like okay he's like okay tell me about
your bell puppy pizza and i was like
let me tell you something i love our
bell pepper pizza and he's like there
you go
yeah yeah he gave me a chance and i was
like ah okay okay okay and i
so he was just to be a little bit fake
to get where you want to go in life and
i took that with me forever
oh so you're saying you're always fake
yeah no a little faith i'm glad we're
all
friends you got to be a little bit fake
on the surface
to get what you want yeah like i [ __ ]
hate steve i don't know but if we're
shooting jk news
i'm just a little bit fake goes a long
way
facts i [ __ ] hate being a little bit
fake
sucks for me so another person commented
this
about this i have horrible anxiety and
struggle to focus on
other stuff other than the actual
process so
i'm sure i've blanked on responding to a
reception it's not because i'm a
rude person and purely because i just
struggle to pay attention to everything
because of the other stuff i'm thinking
of so this is actually nice
and reminds me i need to make sure to
interact which is the post
granted i had had i not been nice i
always make sure to apologize as soon as
i'm able to
if i recognize it even if i don't get
the job so
a lot of people end up being anxious or
insecure or whatever
and then they accidentally are rude
so i guess that's something well they
they have to control their
goddamn feelings exactly so they need to
be aware of that
it also helps out i think in college
like or even in high school they have
those like career
planning things and one of the things to
do is to practice interviews with
your roommate or your friends just so
you can get used to those questions i
went to a course like that
because um when when
i was on welfare they took me to one of
those courses
oh how to get a job on yeah like how to
interview how to do your resume
how to like say the
typical [ __ ] about how your weaknesses
are technically strength
of my weakness right i'll be like step
one
make out with the interviewer
try to at least step two would you like
to make out no make out with the manager
step three make out with your co-workers
yep
step four try to finger try to figure
somebody not anybody
anybody anybody whoever's in the room
finger all your customers put your put
every finger in any hole that's
available to you
that's how they know that you want the
job it's weird too because
i think every company has their own
culture and what they're looking for
so like what might work out for one
company
it might not work out for the illness
very true yeah one of the suggestions
too that they gave us in that course was
that
look up the company you're trying to get
hired by and then if like
before you go into the interview you
have to look up their history look at
the company culture look at their
their uh what is that common thing
i guess motto but the other thing their
policy no
like logan about why their mission
statement
that's that one that's the one i was
looking for their mission statement yeah
what are they trying to accomplish
yeah and see how you fit in with them
and then so it'll
you'll just be able to dude my second
job interview i wrecked it because i was
just like
i was like uh yeah i'm i'm gonna do
i know you probably have a lot of
employees who [ __ ] around on the
internet i'm not gonna do that
and the guy was like [ __ ] okay and i
even said [ __ ] around on the internet
word i had this i liked going into
companies
and then getting accepted for the job
and then declining it
[Laughter]
[ __ ] ego trip baby
well you could use that to leverage
another job offer i know but i wasn't
thinking about business i was thinking
about pride that's good i was like i
came in
and i got that data entry 12 an hour job
[ __ ] you wanted that time
you're one of those girls that flirts
with boys just just to get them to like
her and then she dismisses them
yeah but i gotta have that bodyguard
friend of me to know
to come and pull me away it's like so i
could be like no not too
oh the cockblock friend yeah yeah thank
you girl yeah
i've interviewed anyone a long time but
one of the things i wanted to start
adding to
the list of questions is uh one of them
asks
what is something you don't know how to
do and then now i
give you two minutes and you write me a
plan of how you're gonna accomplish that
that's good so if they go because i
think this is if you give them too much
anxiety and then they say
you gave me a panic attack [ __ ] you oh
that's perfect then i know they're not a
good fit what if their answer is
i'll google it that's perfect that's
exactly what i want to do because
everyone has their answer on their phone
now
so no one has an excuse of not knowing
how to do something
so if they go oh i don't know how to
make an aquarium cool here's two minutes
figure out how to make aquarium
if they could just write down like i'm
gonna work at a gym
no i know but that but we have the
craziest [ __ ] happening at the gym
that like man like it's like the
craziest we need an aquarium stat
yes honestly honestly well i just don't
know what the [ __ ]
what if they're like i don't know how to
make a baby and then they start jacking
off in front we actually don't hire like
meatheads
because they don't know because there's
so many crazy things that happen
at a gym that are actually not even
lifting related
it's like what give me one can't tell
you on camera i'll tell you after i'll
tell you after
but like man all i know is place do you
know how i don't know
i don't know these other things do you
know how interesting it is what you just
said a lot of you can't give me any
examples
it sounds illegal exactly plumbing what
you know one of them oh [ __ ] i do
yeah oh [ __ ] there's like ndas and [ __ ]
remember the aquarium incident
we got a lot of loose fish in here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you